Transcription: santi peralta
Relecteur: Samira Kwache
Je m’appelle Sibylle d’Arfeuille.
J’ai 22 ans depuis peu.
Je suis étudiante en biologie
et je suis ravie d’être avec vous ce soir.
On va faire un petit exercice.
Je vais vous demander de fermer les yeux.
Pensez à une rencontre
qui a changé votre vie.
Comment avez-vous fait cette rencontre ?
Qu’est-ce-qu’elle vous a apporté ?
Qu’est-ce qu’elle a changé
dans votre vie ?
Pour moi, tout a commencé il y a sept ans
dans les couloirs du lycée de seconde.
On peut changer.
Je devais faire un exposé
sur une association.
Je connaissais très peu l’association Aïda
qui n’avait encore que quelques mois.
Je me souviens très bien du moment où
je suis allée voir Léa Moukanas
dans les couloirs de seconde,
avec ma petite liste de questions
et mon billet de 10euros pour acheter
mon premier t-shirt de l’association.
Non seulement j’ai eu
la meilleure note de la classe,
mais à cette époque,
je ne le savais pas encore
que cette rencontre avec Léa
allait changer ma trajectoire de vie.
Sept ans plus tard,
je suis nommée
à la tête de l’association Aïda
en tant que déléguée générale
pour piloter toutes les actions
de l’association en France.
2500 bénévoles,
80 000 jeunes sensibilisés,
2200 patients accompagnés
dans une cinquantaine
de structures hospitalières.
Aujourd’hui, j’ai 22 ans
et je suis convaincue
que la rencontre est l’opportunité
par laquelle naît l’engagement.
Ce soir, nous allons déconstruire
les différentes étapes de l’engagement
à travers trois rencontres
qui ont changé ma vie.
J’ai commencé à m’engager
à l’âge de 14 ans
avec des babysittings bénévoles
pour enfants handicapés,
grâce à une sensibilisation
dans mon collège.
Je faisais régulièrement des babysittings
et j’étais très à l’aise avec les enfants.
Donc, ça me permettait de faire
ce qui me plaît tout en m’engageant.
Première intervention,
je rencontre Madeleine,
six ans, handicapée motrice.
Elle ne pouvait ni communiquer
par la parole, ni par les gestes,
seulement par le regard.
C’est dingue tout ce qu’on peut
ressentir et exprimer avec un seul regard.
Un soir, les parents
sont rentrés de leur sortie
et ils m’ont dit :
« Merci de nous avoir permis
de vivre notre unique cinéma
depuis très longtemps. »
Pour moi, je venais de faire
quelque chose de simple :
garder des enfants, rire avec eux,
raconter des histoires, lire des livres.
Aux yeux des parents, je venais de faire
quelque chose d’extraordinaire.
C’est là que j’ai compris
que l’engagement est à la portée de tous.
Pour une fois, on ne me demandait pas
d’avoir telle ou telle note
ou telle compétence.
Je devais simplement être moi-même.
Et en étant ainsi, je pouvais faire
des choses extraordinaires.
Cette rencontre a été un réel déclic
pour moi, un réel engagement.
[Déclic]
[Tremplin]
(Rires)
J’ai commencé mes études
par une année de PACES
afin de suivre des études de médecine.
Année compliquée, concours raté
et nous ne pouvions plus redoubler
notre première année de PACES.
J'ai donc poursuivi mes études
dans la psychologie.
Je ne m'y sentais pas du tout à ma place.
J’allais en cours le matin
et je rentrais le soir, tel un robot.
Je ne parlais à personne.
Ma place était peut-être en cours
d’anatomie ou en stage infirmier
mais, en aucun cas,
elle était en cours de psychologie.
Au second semestre, on avait une matière
qui s’appelle la neurophysiologie.
La seule matière en psychologie
évoquant de la biologie.
J’ai rencontré ma professeure,
premier cours.
Et là, je me demande
comment cette professeure,
- psychologue de fonction -
enseigne, aujourd’hui, la biologie.
Donc, je vais la voir
à la fin du cours pour lui demander
et pour lui expliquer
mon cursus scolaire.
Et elle me répond : « Sibylle,
je pense que vous devez quitter Paris
et changer de filière d’études.
Je pense qu'elle ne vous convient pas.
Je pense qu’il faut
que vous quittiez Paris
car c’est trop synonyme
d’échec pour vous,
par rapport à votre PACES.
Regardez l'université de biologie à Lyon.
Je pense que ce sont des études
qui peuvent vous correspondre. »
Je me souviendrai toujours,
en sortant de cette salle de classe,
j’ai croisé une camarade qui m’a dit :
« Sibylle, il y a une météorite
qui t’est tombée sur la tête ou quoi ? »
Et c'était le cas.
Cette professeure venait d’ouvrir les yeux
sur mon avenir
et sur mes réelles volontés.
J'avais vraiment jamais pensé
à être chercheur.
Et pourtant, avec l’association Aïda,
j’ai eu l’occasion de rencontrer
beaucoup de chercheurs,
lorsqu’ils parlaient de leur métier,
j’étais passionnée
par ce qu’ils disaient.
Mais je ne me suis jamais
posée la question
parce que j’étais obnubilée
par ce métier de médecin.
Finalement, c’était fait pour moi.
Je suis rentrée le soir,
il restait deux jours sur Parcoursup
pour remplir les dossiers.
J’ai tout misé sur Lyon.
Et j’ai attendu les résultats
pendant ce long premier confinement.
Les résultats sont tombés
et là, je revis.
Je revis parce qu’enfin,
je suis guidée
vers une perspective d’avenir
qui me porte, qui me parle.
Cette professeure a été
un réel tremplin pour moi,
à la fois dans ma vie associative,
dans ma vie professionnelle
et dans ma vie personnelle.
Dans la vie associative parce que
quand on va mieux, quand on va bien,
on peut s’investir pleinement
dans ce qu’on fait.
Et j’ai pu m’engager de façon plus saine
dans l’association Aïda
et ainsi prendre de nouvelles fonctions.
J’ai également créé
ma marque de bijoux - Sy-bijoux -
avec l’aide de ma sœur jumelle Agate.
Donc, merci pour cette rencontre
- à cette professeure
dont je ne me souviendrai jamais
de son nom et de son prénom -
qui m’a permis de réellement
changer de vie
et de me sentir mieux.
Chaque année, l’association Aïda
organise un week-end
qui s’appelle le weekend
« Highway to Health ». C’est quatre jours.
On emmène les jeunes en vacances.
On leur propose des dizaines d’activités.
À mon premier « Highway to Health »,
je rencontre Gabriel.
La première activité de ce week-end,
ça s’appelle le « World Café »
C’est une activité où on propose
aux jeunes d’échanger sur leur maladie,
sur leurs difficultés, sur les problèmes
qu’ils ont pu rencontrer.
Pendant cette activité,
Gabriel se sentait très mal.
Il ne voulait parler à personne.
Il était totalement recroquevillé
sur lui-même avec ses écouteurs
et n’avait qu’une envie,
c’était rentrer chez lui.
Quatre jours après,
Gabriel a écrit une chanson
qu’il a chantée devant 200 jeunes.
Il est venu me voir en me disant :
« Sibylle,
j’ai vécu les meilleures vacances
de ma vie.
S’il te plaît l’année prochaine,
fais en sorte que ces quatre jours
durent un mois. »
J’ai ressenti un million de choses.
Je venais d’avoir
une concrétisation, une confirmation
de ce pourquoi je m’engageais
et me levais tous les jours.
Et encore, un exemple
que lorsqu’on est jeune,
on peut s’engager, on peut
faire des choses incroyables
et concrètes.
[Confirmation]
Un autre exemple de rencontre
qui a réellement confirmé mon engagement,
c'est Charlotte.
Je l’ai rencontrée dans une clinique
à Paris, partenaire de l’association Aïda
et nous étions en train de faire
une activité de fabrication de bijoux.
Au bout de 20 minutes d’activité,
elle me dit : « C’est dingue Sibylle,
avant que vous n’arriviez,
j’avais très mal à la tête.
J’allais très mal.
Je n’avais qu’une envie,
c’était rentrer dans ma chambre
et c’est l’éducatrice
qui m’a motivée à rester.
Et depuis que vous êtes arrivée,
je n’ai plus du tout mal à la tête
et je me sens super heureuse. »
Encore une fois,
un million de choses que je ressens.
On avait eu un impact
à la fois concret physiquement,
pour son mal de tête et moralement.
Et pourtant, encore une fois,
on faisait une action simple.
Nous étions seulement nous-mêmes,
à faire une activité de bijoux
ou à faire un week-end
de quatre jours avec Gabriel.
Et pour eux,
on venait de déplacer des montagnes.
Mon job au quotidien,
c’est justement
de permettre ces rencontres
entre des bénévoles
et des jeunes patients
qui, il y a quelques années,
m’ont permis de m’engager.
Alors l’engagement,
c’est aussi la découverte de soi.
La découverte de soi,
parce qu’on s’engage
un peu vers l’inconnu.
On ne sait pas où on va et
on se découvre des compétences
qu'on ne connaissait pas jusqu'alors.
Et ce qui est génial avec l’engagement
et particulièrement chez Aïda,
c’est qu’on est excité d’apprendre
tous les jours, de se lever chaque matin
parce que c’est en perpétuelle évolution.
J’ai de la chance aujourd’hui
parce que ce que je fais,
c’est le point de rencontre
entre mes études et mon engagement.
Permettre des rencontres
qui changent une vie.
Et vous ?
[Soi-même]
Quelles sont ces rencontres
qui ont changé votre vie ?
qui vous ont permis de prendre
le chemin que vous prenez aujourd’hui ?
Quelles sont ces rencontres, finalement,
qui vous ont permis
de vous découvrir vous-même ?
Parce que oui, sans cet engagement,
sans ces rencontres,
je ne serais pas la personne
que je suis aujourd’hui.
Parce que finalement,
la rencontre que j’ai faite
au fond de ce couloir de seconde,
c’était une rencontre avec moi-même.
Merci pour votre écoute.